if you want to hear the truth about the
game the girl bathwater aid scandal and
stick around to the end of this video
hello and welcome to another exciting
lesson here on horror history
my name is Light Yagami and today we're
gonna be looking at one of Pennywise his
most trusted allies a so called gamer
girl with ties to Satan whose publicity
stunts and money-making schemes have
taken the internet by storm on multiple
occasions so he's battled massive
entities like Mark Zuckerberg the
Brighton Police Department and PewDiePie
and whose bravery and valiant efforts
saved the life of a hamster one time I
am of course referring to Belle Delphine
in order to understand how she came to
being we've got to start at the
beginning so let's take it back to the
birth of Belle Mary Belle Kirchner was
born on October 23rd 1999 in Cape Town
South Africa she was born with a
dislocated hip that required extensive
surgery which likely saved her from a
life confined to a wheelchair and gave
her the ability to do this
Kirchner's father was a Caucasian man
who married a multiracial Japanese woman
and by the time of their daughter's
birth they were living in South Africa
the Japanese heritage of Belle's mother
likely had a large impact on her
interest culturally because she's known
for her anime style cosplays which
include anime and Japanese video game
characters and perhaps her most notable
pose in these photographs is her a hey
gout phases which are a staple of
Japanese hentai she's also been known to
sketch illustrations of manga and
Japanese video game characters her
mother's influence on her life may have
stretched further than that though in an
Instagram QA Bell revealed that her
mother has taken some work as a model
and that this experience made her mom
more accepting of her career choices I
wouldn't be surprised if this worked
both ways and missus Kirchner's early
modeling work helped inspire some of
Belle's fodder II as a young girl Belle
spent a lot of time exploring outdoors
and loved hiking mountain areas and
beaches so when she moves to Brighton in
the United Kingdom and didn't have easy
access to these scenic areas in nature
she took to the Internet to entertain
herself it was here that Belle would
realize the power of the Internet so she
did not yet know the extent at which the
world wide web would alter the course of
her life Belle showed the wits
intelligence and creativity that she
would later use to build a five hundred
thousand dollar business early on in her
school days where she was constantly at
the top of her class in nearly every
subject with the exception of English
and if her patreon page is any
indication she hasn't been able to
improve her English skills in the years
that would follow screen shooting is not
a word there's a comma missing after
hamsters there should not be a comma
here and that's the worst use of an
apostrophe I've ever seen you're my king
and you're helping me unbelievable thank
you so so much it is possible that the
grammatical errors on her patreon are
part of the Lolita aspect of her
character but I'll get back to that when
we get there first Belle would
demonstrate her drive to be successful
and to make money by beginning her first
job at the age of 13 and she worked many
jobs from a young age including being a
barista a dishwasher and waitress among
others I find it interesting that
waitress was among the jobs that she
held even at the young age of 13 because
it's one of the few professions in
English culture where an employee who
plays their cards right can typically
make a few extra pounds from customer
tipping in England wrong from tipping
this seat is optional I wouldn't be
surprised if she picked up a few tips
and tricks fun and definitely intended
that she could use to make some extra
money in another
friendly venture of hers down the line
or premium snapchat it's the year
following her 14th birthday in 2013 was
a life-changing one she dropped out of
school started her own Facebook page
which he named tinker Smith which she
would use to share selfies of herself
and friends online and started a
relationship with a girl named Hannah
the relationship with Hannah along with
the fact that she abandoned her
education may have been a contributing
factor to her leaving home a year later
at the age of 15 to move into a shared
household it was here that she started
her first Instagram account on March
27th 2015 she would make her debut on
the gram which would eventually become
her most successful social media account
this also marked an aesthetic change
which featured more goth looking
photographs with piercings and fake
tattoos she seemed to be heavily
influenced by the style of alternative
pop artist Melanie Martinez Bell's
relationship with Hannah would go on
another year after that but when Belle
was 16 it was over it was around this
time that the stage name and Belle and
Delphine was adopted and she began to
make a more conscious effort to brand
herself in a specific way I think this
was the most important moment in her
career the moments that Mary Belle
Kirchner died and Belle Delphine was
born this was more than just a name
change this was the creation of a
character in the portrayal of this wacky
character is the reason that she's
successful today Belle realized that on
social media your most valuable asset is
the attention of your audience and
having an outlandish character and
exaggerated extension of oneself is an
effective way to garner that attention
combine that with the increasingly
revealing outfits in her posts and Belle
Delphine had a recipe for success but it
would take some time and before her
first big breakthrough in the meantime
she took up babysit now I don't know
what parents took a look at Belle
Delphine decided you know what I think
we should hire to look after our baby I
mean roll the clip put my actual human
hair but to be fair that clip wasn't
online at the time she was babysitting
she started her YouTube channel on July
30th 2016 and in August she would post
her only video of that year a makeup
tutorial that seems to be nothing more
than a makeup tutorial that would bring
in 90 thousand views through its first
two years
gonna be doing my everyday I make up but
like great character youtubers like Dax
flame and Miranda sings before her I
think she realized that she had to start
off a little bit normal and show us that
descent into the occasionally morbid
kawaii girl that we know her as today to
use some of her babysitting money to
fund a van tour through France I guess
she was a few years early on the whole
hashtag van life trend I mean I can only
imagine how successful her how I shower
in the van video would have been
considering the demographic of her
audience in October of 2017 about one
week before her 18th birthday and Belle
would undergo a curious procedure that
would physically change her appearance
forever and to be the subject of
countless conspiracy theories and
speculation in the photo set a plane
that's a plane in the photos leading up
to October 17th 2017 two things our
parents first she's really leaning into
the innocent childlike aspect of her
character by posing with toys and
wearing shirts that say baby girl or
daddy's girl in the second she seems to
have perfect teeth at least the top row
doesn't look like it needs any work
which made it very curious when she
posted a photo wearing braces which she
supposedly got for free not sure why but
this led to a lot of speculation about
her motives
she was only one week from turning 18
and I think the braces were stunts to
revitalize her Lolita image as she moved
into adulthood she has on multiple
occasions used the Lolita culture as
part of her character in one video
wearing a Lolita shirt and it just seems
like she feels like that's an important
part of her character because despite
marketing herself as an adult symbol she
never technically crosses into adult
content instead opting to do memes and
just straight-up weird stuff like the
whole thing is really more of a satire
act than anything even if that's not
what some of her paid patrons are
probably there for but I think that's
kind of what makes the next two years of
her story so funny is that there's just
like this sharp contrast between what
she claims to be doing and what she's
actually doing because immediately after
getting the free braces she starts
posting the a hey guy owes and if you're
not familiar with Japanese culture a hey
guy was basically this trope that's seen
a lot in hentai or adult-only manga used
to denotes a woman who's feeling extreme
pleasure so this becomes Bell's new
moneymaker and I'm not talking about
monopoly
because in March of 2018 she would open
a patreon where she would allow the
Internet's thirstiest gamers and most
desperate youtubers to donate money or
pay a monthly fee for lewd photos and
for $25 these in cells can gain access
to her entire collection of a hangout
content the account had over 1,000
patrons within six months and with the
average pledged up around six dollars
and seventy cents at the time Belle was
probably earning over seven thousand
dollars per month on patreon alone and
that's before you factor in large
one-time donations like the 2500 that
will and he paid her to make a video to
help him in the subscriber battle with
morgues mom please turn that off and the
three grand that pyrocynical donated and
hopes that Belle would play fortnight
with them nice cover story pyro rise up
gamers butts between her now booming
Instagram her lucrative patreon and her
exploding tick-tock that earned her a
spot on roughly 75% of all tick-tock
compilation thumbnails on YouTube Elle
Delphine had officially reached meme
status with the most popular Belle
Delphine memes being this a Haga one and
her take on yin-yang cosplay is truly
transcendent tick-tock dance hit or miss
yeah truly an artist at our time kill me
in September 2018 bail would finally
come out with her second YouTube video
and in typical you thought fashion it's
a room tour so in typical member of the
male species fashion I'm gonna roll it
[Music]
okay I thought Sofia Coppola knew how to
start off a movie when she made lost in
translation I'm kidding I'm kidding
I'm Katie but the room tour is a great
example of what makes Belle as
interesting as she is the majority of
her room is overwhelmingly cutesy in
Kauai which just makes it ten times
better when she reveals her wall of
animal skulls the paddle masochistic
treatments of teddy bears and collection
of firearms it's a really we have to
find house okay I'm suddenly regretting
memeing on her for now I mean at least
she's over in the UK it's not like you
can get a gun into the u.s. right
before the year's end Bell would find
herself in the news after a fake article
titled the judge orders premium snapchat
model to pay sixty thousand in taxes to
IRS after multiple reports by Internet
users was released and although the
website Hustler's calm is known for its
satire articles general public did not
know that and the story picked up a fair
amount of traction and I think seeing
this buzz over her in the media gave
Bell an idea a light bulb went off in
her head despite this hilarious comments
and it helped her form a new PR strategy
going forward in 2019 which would be her
craziest year ever she kicked it off
with an appearance on the then biggest
channel on YouTube by posting advance to
PewDiePie's famous TV series distract
which he then reacted to and obviously
used her image in the thumbnail for
those game reviews Thank You pal
Delphine very cool now I can use her in
the thumbnail for millions of extra
abuse thank you to help Elfie this is a
blessing she would spend most of the
first five months of that year planning
and creating a library of content
remember how I said that she has to
start with something relatively tame but
then slowly descend into madness well on
June 14th she reached the bottom of that
descent when she uploaded her third
youtube video titled meet my best friend
oh okay this is nice she's just making
some manga sketches with her friend
she's actually pretty good okay it's a
dead octopus with googly eyes and she's
touching it and it's touching her food
and it's getting all over her bath more
on that later okay not gonna lie I'm
kinda jealous two days later she joined
Twitter so that she could broadcast to a
wider audience than those just following
her on patreon but it would be Instagram
her biggest platform with over 4 million
followers where she would make her next
big announcement on June 16th 2019 she
posted a photo with the caption if this
video gets 1 million likes I'll actually
make a hub account the time has
officially come Tiger friends / dad to
help you - which of the hub themselves
were ecstatic and so was the internet so
four days later the photo had reached 1
million likes and Belle stayed true to
her word and created an account on a hub
she would upload a total of 12 videos
which I will show after the break
I'm not going to repeat the titles of
Bell Delphine's upload on the hub but as
promised I will show you some of the
footage of the clickbait videos that she
posted there like this one where she
plays with a pair of large chickens this
one where a mysterious hand helps her
cook kind of and complete an i dubs meme
I have osteoporosis or this one where
she squirts a water gun while wearing a
squirtle shirts if you didn't believe
what I said about her being more of a
performance artist than an actual adult
model I think these twelve videos will
set the record straight there's even one
where she just simply eats a burger on
camera a reference to a famous video
that the artist Andy Warhol made in 1982
where he does just that
Rolex okay that's enough stop rolling it
okay seriously stop rolling it yeah
despite her hub content having no actual
graphic content some of her audience
seemed to have no issue with that but
the videos were majority downvoted even
the one where she eats a picture of
PewDiePie which got her another reaction
from him on that week's episode of lie
PewDiePie goes all the way inside Belle
Delphine marzia pizza time stop the
videos in the hub would bring in between
300,000 and 3.6 million views at the
time of recording and more importantly
it got a lot of people talking about
beldar theme however there would be one
unintended side effect later that month
the hand of Mark Zuckerberg taketh away
and Instagram struck down her account
this had a deep emotional toll on the 19
year old social media star actually I
made that up but why the am I even
making this video but her next big
business venture which would become her
biggest business venture was right
around the corner on July 3rd 2019 Belle
Delphine announced on Twitter I am now
selling my bathwater this is what
humanity has come to smiley emoji get
yours here WWL Delphine store calm the
bathwater which one for $30 at the time
sold out in under 8 hours people paid
money to acquire water I can't I really
can't and you can't blame Belfort a
advantage of a business opportunity but
who are these people how desperate do
you have to be so after the bathwater
sold out a number of things happened
first she became a mean again everyone
was making bathwater videos some real
some fake someone drinking the gamer
girl bathwater my friends mr.
creepypasta and Vincent vena cava even
did a creepypasta narration video about
it you should have seen her pink hair
the tightest little body those eyes
those big round anime eyes she was like
a hentai drawing come to life then the
accusation started coming out a headline
was posted to Twitter from an account
posing as the British newspaper Daily
Mail which said over 50 people have
reportedly contracted herpes after
drinking Instagram starbella Delphine's
bathwater like the fake IRS scandal some
people believed it and rumors once again
spread and for a couple days there it
seemed like a fact and most of us were
wondering if she was gonna get sued and
there were actually multiple fake
reports that floated round after that
and then over the past few days the news
broke and I'm saying news because it's
not a real thing but it broke but one
person sent to hospital after drinking
internet personalities bath water some
people started to figure out that this
was a hoax on July 9th when the
fact-checking website snopes.com
verified the information is false also
citing subsequent tweets from the
Twitter account that started it between
July 7 and July 9 at bay phrases
intermittently tracked how their hoax
tweet had caused the number of their
followers to explode while another tweet
explicitly stated it seemed the best way
to grow on Twitter was to impersonate a
company and say things about a celebrity
that can legally be considered libel and
I could potentially be sued for and have
wiser words really ever been spoken
don't answer that so next day bail
cleared everything up when she
officially made a statement putting the
rumors to rest but I do have to commend
her on the decision to wait one week
before doing so and take all the free
press she may have gotten the idea for
selling bath water from the Matt
Groening show disenchantment where a man
known as the decrepit peddler has a
similar business now this could be a
coincidence but I'm thinking it's not
because in one of her photos she's
wearing a t-shirt referencing a segment
from Matt greatings previous show
Futurama
oh my god there's Jake Finkel Berg he's
so hot I wish it wasn't my brother that
always makes me laugh I love Futurama
also I think Belle Delphine could make
an awesome cosplay of Princess TIA
beanie from disenchantment I mean they
just somehow kind of look alike
eventually the bath water came back into
stock at a much higher price point along
with the $50 gamer girl chewed gum and
the $10,000 gamer girl pea she actually
felt the need to put the disclaimer this
is not for drinking so even as the
bathwater thing evaporated that'll
continue to gain notoriety when Ethan
Klein came up with a new disgusting
product idea on his weekly show of the
h3 podcast so what I was proposing to
her is that if you will make a tea
reward call it Ethan to her above God
and the reward is I will fart at a mason
jar and mail it to so Miz Delphine if we
want to call her that decided to send
Ethan a mystery box which he received on
July 21st and opened on the podcast
hello h3h3 I hope you got my little box
and no it's not my dirty socks it's a
little weird
I must admit but I sent you a bottle of
my own oh it's a pollen it's not what
you're thinking
Ethan and HeLa received a jar full of
gamer girl spits along with the flash
drive containing the proof that this is
actually her spits oh and a hats
honestly it's pretty nice hats the
podcast netted 1 million views and the
VOD added another 1.6 mill
guess who was featured on the thumbnails
it wasn't Jason Blum so that's basically
the peak I mean there was this thing in
late July or early August where she
supposedly was hospitalized while
vacationing in Greece but who knows if
that actually even happened but at least
she looks hot in the photo then there
was October 7th where she claimed to
have been arrested and went on to
explain I swear this girl came into my
party and stole my hamster I have no
idea why or who the Frick does that I
spray painted the heck out of her car
and got arrested at least I got my
hamster back not too many big youtubers
fell for it this time but if enough
small youtubers talk about it then she
can still get a DS
amount of attention from it and that's
exactly what happened she's now in a
never-ending cycle of outrageous PR
moves which are boosted by thirsty gamer
boys talking about it which then leads
to another outrageous PR move her net
worth is reportedly over 500 grand and
she continues to post weird stuff and
grow her ever-expanding fanbase so that
concludes today's lesson on horror
history if you didn't drop out like
Belle Delphine did then your assignment
isn't like this video and let me know in
the comments who I should cover on the
next horror history if you want to see
my analysis of other horror characters
then click that playlist on the left and
remember to subscribe to seize these
worlds for new Horrors every week ring
that death bell Delphine for
notifications and I'll see you in the
next one and if you're wondering why I
did a horror history on an a thoughts
you might want to check the dates of
this upload assuming we both survived